sección número 5 del examen número 7 y
bueno este es el primer vídeo
problema número uno dice si tenemos la
sucesión siguiente 26
14 14 y 30
ok en donde el término iniciales 2 bueno
aquí está te lo presento este es mi
término inicial y dice cada término
siguiente resulta de sumarle 1 al
término anterior y duplicarlo ok si te
das cuenta de aquí para acá lo que
hicimos fue primero a este 2
le sumamos 1 y llegamos al 3 y el 3 y lo
multiplicamos por 2 lo multiplicamos por
2 de aquí para acá lo que hacemos es a
sumar 1 sumamos 1 y llegamos al 7 y el 7
lo multiplicamos por 2 aunque sea flecha
a al 7 lo multiplicamos por 2 y el 14
pues el 14 hicimos lo mismo nosotros
tomamos el 14 le sumamos 1 le sumamos 1
y llegamos al 15 y después lo
multiplicamos por 2 lo multiplicamos por
2 y lo que nos dicen es cuál es el sexto
término y bueno para no calcular la
fórmula y todo eso a mucho me ocurre que
ya tenemos el cuarto porque no sacamos
el quinto y el sexto
entonces el quinto es tomarnos el 30
a sumarle 1 llegamos al 31 y al 31 lo
multiplicó por 2 multiplicó por 2 y me
da 62 ok y ahora trabajemos con el 62 al
62 y le voy a sumar 1 ok voy a llegar 63
ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por 2 lo
voy a multiplicar por 2 y es 6 126 el
sexto término de esta obsesión es 126
que es el insisto el de lujo problema
número 2 problema número 2 dice si a x x
más bien esto es igual a 45 y por otra
parte me dicen que a x es igual a 15 ok
a lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale
apoye apoyen a que es igual y bueno
realmente este problema es muy sencillo
lo que necesitamos es la propia
distributiva este por este este por este
entonces de esta ecuación de que arriba
me quedaría que por x más a por james es
igual a 45 pero nosotros sabemos jajaja
que por x es igual a 15 entonces vamos a
enchufar lo por acá vamos a sustituirlo
y entonces me va a quedar que 15 más a
porque es igual a 45 y de aquí puedo
obtener el valor de apoye que eso es lo
que yo quiero a por james es igual a 45
menos a 45 menos 15 lo cual es 30 a
porque es 30 que es justo la solución de
este problema que es el inciso e de lujo
2 incisos m
vamos al problema número
así que volvemos la pantalla y pensamos
ahora en el problema número 3 que dice
en el velocímetro siguiente cuál es la
velocidad dada en kilómetros programa
indicada por la posición de la aguja ok
tenemos que hacer la posición de la
aguja
venga tengo primero una una curva así
después tengo otra curva así y después
tengo otra curva así de lugo la primera
está dada en metros sobre el segundo la
segunda está dada en millas por hora
ok la tercera está dada en kilómetros
por hora y bueno aquí en donde estamos
en kilómetros por hora tenemos por aquí
al 30
tenemos una
3 y por acá tengo al 60 ok y solamente
voy a dibujar el km por hora en la
escala de estos kilómetros por hora
porque escucho lo que me preguntan cuál
es la velocidad dada en kilómetros por
hora y la aguja que me mencionan es
justo
esta es una flecha que va más o menos
por aquí ok es una flecha que va más o
menos por aquí
ok y que sabemos nosotros bueno que aquí
tenemos dividido en 1 2 3 4 partes del
30 al 60
así que si dividimos justo en la mitad
justo en la mitad cuales la mitad de 60
y 30 bueno pues el promedio de 60 y 30
es 45 estás de acuerdo si yo tomo 60 más
30 entre 2 es 45 pero yo me quiero fijar
en este valor que tengo aquí en este
punto que tengo aquí que es la mitad de
entre la mitad de 30 y 60 es decir de 45
y 30 yo me quiero fijar en la mitad de
45 y 30 45 más 30 entre 2 es lo mismo
que 75 entre 2 y esto
aquí va un 33 por 2-6 7-6 es 1 bajó el 5
y me queda 77 por 214 sobra uno bajo un
cero por un punto y me queda aquí un 5
es decir que la flecha con la aguja de
este velocímetro
a 37 puntos 5 kilómetros por hora y esa
es la respuesta de este problema que por
cierto es el sexto b ya está lo único
que tenemos que hacer es aplicarnos en
la mitad de 60 y 30 y después en la
mitad de 30 y 45 que por cierto esto es
lo mismo que decir a 30 de que acá hay
32 unidades 30 unidades entre 4 lo cual
es 7.5 ya esto a al 30 de aquí son más
de 7.5 llegaríamos justo a 37.5 ok bueno
es otra forma de verlo pero vamos a
hacer el problema número 4 el programa
número 4 y me cabe aquí dice cuántos
enteros de tres dígitos se pueden formar
usando forzosamente los números 4 5 y 6
4 5 y 6 y esencialmente lo que me
preguntan es cuántas combinaciones hay
del número 456 y bueno hay dos formas de
resolverlo la primera sería bueno
permitir estos números me quedaría 4 6 5
y ahora siempre sabemos con 5 que daría
5 6 4 y 5 4 6 y ahora también podemos
empezar con 6 654 y también nos quedaría
el 64 5 lo cual son
seis números la respuesta sería 6 o
también lo podemos ver como que en el
primer sitio aquí podemos poner 3
números por lo tanto no quedaría 3 x en
el segundo sitio solamente podemos poner
dos números si escogimos 1 en el primer
sitio 3 por 2 por y en el último sitio
pues pondríamos el que me sobra 3 por 2
por 1 lo cual también es 6 2 formas
distintas de ver este problema ok vamos
a hacer el siguiente problema problema
número 5 para esto paramos la pantalla y
voy a trabajar el problema número 5 que
dice lo siguiente ok y tengo la
siguiente figura
ok vamos a ponerle tengo a un triángulo
por aquí es más déjenme ponerle un poco
más abajo
tengo un tenido por aquí algo así algo
así y algo así ok y tengo una recta como
por aquí algo más o menos así tengo otra
recta como por aquí más o menos así
algunos sub no sé si tengo esta parte de
aquí ok y ya te estás imaginando a qué
me refiero con esto de hecho tengo
líneas punteadas así que vamos a
intentar las hacer tengo una línea
punteada por aquí algo más o menos así
ok y otra línea punteada por acá algo
más o menos así a la parte más difícil
de todos estos problemas a veces es
dibujar la figura pero creo que ya va
quedando ya no estamos tan lejos tengo
otra parte punteada más o menos así
una línea punteada más o menos así ya
está de lujo más o menos me queda la
figura dice es un prisma de base
triangular y dice en la siguiente figura
en la figura número 5 tenemos un prisma
cuya base es un triángulo y cuyos lados
es un rectángulo y además sabemos que el
área el área de cada uno de los
rectángulos es r pongámoslo así el área
de los rectángulos es r es decir que el
área por ejemplo de esto que tengo aquí
desde que tengo aquí el área de todo
esto el área de este rectángulo que
tengo aquí es r
ok y el área de los triángulos es de el
área de los triángulos estén ok por
ejemplo esta área esto que tengo aquí
esto es
muy bien lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale el área total de la figura cuánto
vale el área total de la figura aunque
después con mucho cuidado vamos a contar
tengo aquí atrás un triángulo tengo este
tema de aquí ok y tengo por otra parte
este de aquí atrás tengo este otro
triángulo justo por acá tengo estos dos
triángulos este y este que tengo aquí ok
ahora solamente tengo dos triángulos y
por lo tanto el área del triángulo de
tenemos que multiplicar por dos el área
total es dos veces el área del triángulo
porque tengo dos triángulos ya esto
tengo que sumar a el área del rectángulo
pero cuántas veces aquí tengo un
rectángulo pero si te das cuenta acá
atrás justo detrás de mí tengo otro
rectángulo este de khan es también otro
rectángulo porque une a dos lados a este
lado ya al otro lado del texto a este
lado ya este lado del triángulo por lo
tanto tengo aquí otro rectángulo este
rectángulo que se forma justo aquí aquí
aunque y con esta línea punteada que
atrás y cuando esté bien pudiera que
atrás
ahora por otra parte también tengo otro
rectángulo aquí en la base del suelo si
te das cuenta este también es un
rectángulo porque tengo un lado tengo
aquí otro lado este lado que está muy
largo que tengo acá ok
también tengo aquí otro lado y aquí está
tiene punteada también me forman el otro
lado de este rectángulo que tengo acá
abajo es decir que tengo 123 rectángulos
por lo tanto al área total a estos dos
tema aunque sumar tres veces el área del
rectángulo tres veces el área de un
rectángulo dicho otra manera el área
total la puedo ver como dos veces este
más tres veces r dos veces el área de
estos triángulos más tres veces el área
del rectángulo porque son tres ok ya
estuvo bueno con esto problema número
cinco bien problema número seis problema
número seis dice
si n 1 / 2 a la n es igual a un medio
cuánto vale
n lo que me preguntan es el valor de m
keith y cómo podemos resolver este
problema
a ver qué te parece si para empezar
multiplicamos todo por 2 alain no va a
quedar que n 1 es igual a un medio que
multiplica a 2 en la n pero un medio un
medio esto es lo mismo que 2 al menos 12
elevado al menos uno o sea que voy a
obtener que n más uno es igual a dos a
la n por dos al menos uno que por cierto
esto es lo mismo por las leyes los
exponentes que 2 elevado a la enee menos
ok
tú puedes ver algo puedes ver la
solución de este problema en más uno es
igual a 2 elevado a la enee menos 1
no quiero tomar logaritmos más de dos no
debe de ser más fácil
no se me ocurre es la respuesta ahorita
qué te parece si nos fijamos en los
incisos vamos a ver inciso a
empiezo aquí nos gusta más empezar aquí
si el naval de uno me quedaría uno más
uno entre dos lo cual es dos entre dos
lo cual es uno y uno nuestro medio por
lo tanto esta no es mi respuesta
veamos inciso b en 2
esto me quedaría que n vale 2 entonces 2
más 1 entre 2 al cuadrado es lo mismo
que tres cuartos y esto tampoco tampoco
es un medio ok
intentemos con css3 me quedaría tres más
uno entre dos al cubo lo cual es 4 entre
8 lo cual si cierto es un medio 4 la
mitad de 8 por lo tanto mi respuesta es
el inciso c pero date cuenta de lo
siguiente como el problema no me salió
el principio y es un problema 4 tiempo
intenté con cada uno de los incisos
hasta encontrar la respuesta correcta no
creo que sea la mejor forma de resolver
un problema pero en este momento mi
mente se bloqueó y no encuentro la forma
de resolver este problema de hecho si te
encuentras la forma de resolver este
problema sería muy bueno que me lo
hiciera saber mandame un mensaje o pongo
un comentario abajo de este vídeo para
saber cómo resolverías tú porque
realmente no se me ocurre la respuesta
correcta la forma de encontrar desde
este
el valor de m y bueno esto lo hago
compresión de tiempo porque recuerda que
el examen del st es un examen
contrarreloj
bueno pero ya quedó la solución la
solución es el inciso c que dice que n
es igual a 3 hasta la próxima